everybody ready
how's the volume here
a little bit higher
okay sorry
okay
greetings
my name is officer alan overa i'm with
the city of henderson police
department's office of public
information
and i'm here to give an initial briefing
on an officer-involved shooting that
occurred today
within the las vegas metropolitan police
department's jurisdiction
today september 21st at approximately 3
44 p.m
this is the second officer-involved
shooting for 2021
the information i'm about to provide
is very preliminary in the investigation
the information i'm about to provide
can change
as the investigation continues so please
be mindful of that
at approximately 3 44 pm
henderson swat officers were dispatched
to the 3000 block
of east charleston boulevard
as requested by las vegas metropolitan
police department's patrol units
referenced an armed subject
upon
the initial encounter with the suspect
an officer-involved shooting occurred
where two henderson swat officers
discharged their firearms striking the
suspect
medical services were provided to the
suspect
however
the suspect was pronounced deceased on
scene
no other injuries were reported during
this incident
now i'll open it up for a couple
questions
i don't have that information right now
neither the two scenes were related were
they
i'm not familiar with the second scene
that you're referring to so no this is
the only scene that henderson swat
officers were responding to
earlier
no sir those situations are totally
independent
yeah what's next from here
i'm sorry sir
i i don't have any of those details for
you right now sir i'm sorry about that
what's next from
here for a few more
the next procedure hours guess
well our investigations bureau is going
to be
doing their normal course um as far as
what we will be able to provide as soon
as we have more information available we
will be disseminating that to the media
during normal course right
that's all i'm going to be doing today
for you guys so thank you um
for coming out and we will provide more
as it becomes available
thank you
you